all you need is uh to have a good good
honest attitude and your techniques or
be an abundance
it's going to come up my ghee
I've essentially said it's in his book I
initiate
many people in other Aikido schools Yuki
initiates and then
it looks like this
like this so it looks like it's it looks
like it's quick
it looks like they attack you what you
have to do in kihon is ah you have to
initiate
now sometimes yes please sit Comfort if
your knees hurt
yeah
sometimes the initiation can be confused
between them attacking
and you're initiating
it's a matter of time so if he starts to
initiate
and then I'll put my hand out oh it's
too late it's his turn to do Aikido
the wife of Harmony spirit
if he starts to come up
and I pick up that movement I actually
initiate and keep going through him
so there's quite a confusion now who is
really winning and losing and
so we'll do no sense his way has taught
to me by cytosensei
ah I initiate
this is an open hand coach you huh it's
then when you take it you don't need to
take it because you have it firm here
for this one
and then pin them down
it's at right angles to their body
this is no good
he can escape
this is just enough
you pin them down the disc
you can do this
if you wish
ah
just go to the
that's good enough
you don't have to do a Chic all the way
back
because you've got him anyhow so if I
want to talk to you and he wants to get
up
it's all to do with angles
there's angles in every part of
somebody's body
I've got make sure that I know his angle
here
see I've got it there he'd know you
perhaps
okay
I can keep talking to you as long as
I've got that angle lose the angle
you have nothing
if you have bad news
you do it standing
up
if you have bad knees
you do it standing
foreign
so you have a nice form
don't
want to go
please they put the wrong hand up
I know the right one please it's as easy
as that
try not to change your mind wrong hand
cut them down and a tummy
I'm just going a little pushes so it's
it's good it's not being nasty it's just
uh teach them that if they don't put the
other hand up
they get their nose bent but in a nice
way don't do it harshly
correct hand all right
you can see though how quick somebody
who's been around can react
open up ah
now many of you because this person's
here
you're doing this and you're giving way
you're then taking down here that's no
good you've got to collapse this front
knee
in this manner
you've got to be going into them
go into them
so there's a two things that yohuki has
to learn one is not to put the wrong
hand up
because they don't know what one I'm
coming up with do they because if I do
it quick
and no sense he said that Aikido is 99
of Tammy and the temi
brings them out
you must go into them drive into so that
if he doesn't get the Shoulder out
they suffer
that way they learn slowly how to get it
out the way
this is the order
I've done this before last time I came
so I don't want to spend too long on it
this time
foreign
but we'll do these ones first
uh
[Music]
Sooners you let him go put your hand up
what
happens
you're cool out there spirit